it's that time to turn that great idea
that you have
that you won't tell anyone about into a
reality with squarespace
squarespace makes it easier than ever to
launch your passion project whether
you're showcasing your work
or selling products of any kind with
beautiful templates and the ability to
customize just about anything
you can easily make a beautiful website
all by yourself but if you do get stuck
their 24 7 award-winning customer
support is there to help you out so head
to squarespace.com
grace for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code grace
to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
get ready for a very wonderful episode
with the one and only alaska thunder
[__]
5000 the stunning and silly alien that's
here to save us all
we talk about everything her drag race
experience her new holiday single let it
snow
the race chaser podcast started with
willem who would survive
in a horror film her or willem uh the
little pound cake dolls in the making uh
you can get your cursed
doll now it was a really wonderful
conversation ufos were talked about
holidays were talked about
pandemic pivoting was talked about i
hope you enjoy this
as much as i did enjoy not too deep with
elasta
alasta alaska thunder [__] 5
000.
[Music]
alaska thank you so much for being here
oh my gosh please thank you for having
me uh
i'm i'm glad i caught you uh after the
slopes
when you have some down time in your
beautiful cabin
definitely yeah this is the apres ski
yes yes
right now yeah now can i ask you
are you being alaska are you a skier
in any form shape fashion
well skiing is a sport so
no so no not at all absolutely not
no skiing is like terrifying like
what i agree it's hurting
down a hill in the snow no thank you no
thank you uh
i'm big into spectator sports being the
spectator of
sports that's more my speed
very bad well let's talk let's jump
right into
first of all it's the holiday season
you're in the winter wonderland can we
talk about let it snow the new holiday
single
oh my gosh yes
what can you tell us about this how are
you
first of all are you a holiday person do
you decorate for the season do you get
excited do you bake cookies
all the stuff i don't you don't want to
see me bake
anything honestly um
my well i don't anymore but for a while
i was using my
um oven and my stove as wig storage
so no that's not the vibe
but i do like being festive
and i did put up my tree which i got
from cvs absolutely it's just a
it's a gorgeous very sparse
uh pre-lit plug-in
false tree i love it that description
could be used for so many different
things
i feel like this season
this year that's uh yeah how we describe
all of us this year
girl i'm false and pre-lit and sparse
exactly now how do you i mean you've
been making music
for so many years now and let it snow is
the newest single so
how do you approach making music what's
your
method if you have one or is it
different every time
well it's always like oh my gosh like
it's always like oh god it's so much
work to like do and like to
write and then you get the like
first version back from the studio and
you hear it and it's like
oh my god when are we doing the next one
like i love
doing music yeah and let us know was
really fun i
because i started working with um ivan
and peter who are
these like space space men who are
like time travelers perfect um who are
also
you know fictitious um
but i started working with them um over
the summer
and we got together and we did let it
snow and
it was really really fun and i got to
like sing and
it's really gay and like upbeat and i
love it
and it mean it's something we all
deserve at the end of this year
which kind of goes into my next
question about how you've been able to
maintain your creativity this year i've
been talking to a lot of drag queens and
i'm always inspired by
just the pure ability to pivot to
uh you know reassess the situation and
still get
your gig going and so i'm curious how
this year has been for you
oh my gosh i mean that's what i was i
was really impressed and really inspired
by that as well
because it's like no not like the
apocalypse can happen
and the next day there will be a drag
show i can
guarantee you we don't we don't sit and
wait around and like
when when am i gonna get my when am i
going to get my chance
to perform we're like okay uh clubs are
all closed
all right instagram live um zoom
um whatever so like that is really
inspiring because like anything
can happen but drag shall persist
truly and you've been doing a lot more
drive-in shows this year i'm curious how
that experiences versus like a normal
bar situation
i mean it's obviously very different but
you guys have been able to like
still keep the show going it's so
it's so um weird and i never
thought it's like the it's like 2020 is
the year of
i never thought that i would see myself
in this situation
i never thought i would see myself
screaming at
cars in a macy's parking lot i never
ever thought it would happen but it did
and it was
it was wonderful because i got to scream
at real people
yeah it look zoom and the technology and
and youtube and um and instagram they're
all fabulous technologies but there's
nothing that can simulate like real
people
seeing their eyes as i'm
teetering on heels and singing and
screaming on stage
the pure experience now
i want to go back to the beginning
because i'm curious about your start in
drag you grew up in pennsylvania
sure did erie pennsylvania oh now how
did you
how would you describe that for anyone
that is not familiar
erie pennsylvania is a is a small city
but
um we um we're convinced that it's a
really
important big city um
like after 9 11 happened um
eerie we were convinced that we were
going to be the next
strike target because we're on the lake
so like hello we have a peninsula
we were next yeah um
we also love like the weather is just
not probable for human like
for humans it's really really cold most
of the year and then it's really really
hot for a few months
so like we love complaining about it but
we never
leave now did you
get interested in drag in eerie or
did this happen later on
i feel like i've kind of been like
interested in drag my entire life like
ever since i was a kid
because i was always just like i like
girl stuff
because it's prettier and more fun yeah
like you can't they don't make clothes
for gi joe
um you can't change his clothes his
clothes are plastic and built on his
body
so like no yeah so
so it like it was dumb so so like i
don't know i've always liked girl stuff
and so like luckily then i found drag
and i was like oh this
yeah this makes sense yeah this is the
vibe
the well you okay so you studied
theater at the university of pittsburgh
is that true
yes okay and what was that scene
like well
it was great and i'm i'm really glad
that i got to go
to pitt because like i tried to get into
the
the good schools for theater and i like
the really major like carnegie mellon
i tried but they were like we don't know
what to do with this person
but but i got into pitt and i'm really
glad i did because
it was a very like well-rounded program
like so i was like learning how to act
and like whatever but i was also like
you had to like
learn how to drill [__] and put the
lights up and like
[__] like uh design costumes and
design sets
so like i feel blessed
that i'm actually using my degree i'm so
blessed
i know i mean if we look at your setup
right now it looks like you had a
theater degree from pitt
right now like just full
thank you i can see the set design the
lighting
all of it it's incredible thank you for
that
now where did you go after pennsylvania
did you go right to los angeles did you
go
to new york los angeles which how did it
end up
well it was either going to be new york
or and my best friend jeremy
got into ucla so he was he was out here
already
and so i was like that's the one we're
doing it
let's go and what was that like what was
the experience coming to los
angeles i'm sure it was overwhelming
horrible
that's the word yeah it's right it's the
same
story just over and over it's like i
came out here and i was like i'm gonna
i'm gonna quit this
silly drag thing and i'm just gonna be
an actor
oh okay so you came out to quit and to
be a serious actor
yeah that didn't yeah that didn't work
out though i was like
how do actors do it's so it's such hard
work and so much rejection and no glory
and like
like a skinny kind of femme
like like male kind of presenting
person and i was like i don't fit in
anywhere and if i get
cast in anything i don't know what role
that's gonna be
so drag saved me like i just i was doing
drag
for fun and then i ended up getting like
jobs and
getting paid for it so i was like maybe
i should just do this
this one this option seems more viable
how did uh now how did you develop the
persona
was it like was this your first kind of
take
on your drag persona or did this develop
over time
did you have any other iterations any
other names or anything
marijuana mostly is the reason yeah
it's sort of i and i'm you know i'm
luckily one of those
drag queens who who um
who named herself and stuck with the
name
um because a lot of times you're like
this is my drag name but then you
realize six months later like
this is a horrible drag name so like
luckily mine was really easy to spell
it was really like it was funny to say
it
i'm named after marijuana so like
it it's sort of i don't know and the
fact that she was like an
extraterrestrial that just all sort of
like beamed into my head
and analyzing it now i i sort of see it
as like
i don't know i think i felt like an
alien being from pennsylvania and
moving to la and yeah it feels like a
lot of like life story was like
unconsciously written into this
character for you
perhaps perhaps
[Music]
well i think one of the coolest things
in my opinion about your style is that
it seems
very effortless and it seems very
whatever
but there is a lot of thought behind it
there is a lot of
like try behind it in like a really
great way
is that you have a it seems like you
have a very
clear picture in your head of the
persona that you want to put out there
even though it comes across completely
effortless and just like
uh by accident almost and is that
something that you work on
behind the scenes like everything seems
even on drag race on everything seems
very thoughtful
everything you put out there
yeah uh yeah i don't know yeah
sure i don't know
i don't know i'm so you know i'm so much
making it up and i'm and i'm
so like i know what i like and i
ultimately know like what i like looking
like and feeling like in drag like it's
such a like
it's such a feeling so like
i don't know i guess that's i guess
that's where it comes from like i can
try like the new thing i can try like
the new fashions and the new hair but i
always just come back to the same old
[__] thing because it's just like
it's just
yeah it's what makes you feel good and
feel right in what you're doing
um okay real question about aliens
ufos i've been watching a lot of
documentaries lately
what are your thoughts on them not to
get so
tummed along on you right now but
they're always the alien shows are
always at like the top of the
suggested on netflix are they preparing
us
for the galactic you know i feel like
there's something
this year has been a year of testing us
in a sense
uh but i'm curious is that something
that you're genuinely
interested in the idea of ufos and
aliens
uh yes i love that stuff i had like a
velvet poster of like an
alien in my bedroom when i was like a
teenager like i
love that [__] yes and i just
i just saw like and it's very likely
that there
are aliens and they're like whoa
i'm not going near that [__] mess
yeah
that is a mess i'm just not going to
engage i'm not going to make eye contact
no we've truly [__] it up for
ourselves there's no way i feel like we
had a window in which they could come
and save us and that window is gone
now yeah they they boarded it over they
painted over it
the window is completely gone exactly um
okay
speaking of aliens let's talk about your
relationship with willam
how did how did you two
meet each other do you do you remember
when you first met
oh my goodness i mean willem is one of
those
people who works so hard and and has
such a like drive that yeah even before
like she was on drag race or whatever
she was still sort of like we kind of
knew who she was because she's always
popping up on tv shows
she had music videos before anybody had
music videos in drag
she was really like doing the thing and
she still is
and so i knew about her for a while then
she was on season four then we were like
kind of we knew each other through drag
race and
and then we beca we didn't like each
other uh
for for a short period of time but
really
sometimes that's how it goes is that
when you see someone that's kind of like
a kismet spirit
that you don't like them at first
because you identify so much with them
in some way it was very it was a little
bit of that
we were both going through our own like
conflama
and then we came together and now you
know
now we're doing this great podcast
together and
like it's yeah yeah
yeah how did that come about was that an
idea from
you guys or was that something presented
to you to do
no we stole the idea pretty much
there is a golden girls podcast called
out on the lanai
and i'm really good friends with the
people who who
made the podcast um h allen's cat
yes yeah yeah he's in bed yeah yeah
um sadie pines hi um
yeah so they do they did this podcast
where they
would watch an episode of the golden
girls and then they would talk about it
yeah and willem and i were stuck in the
line trying to exit burning man
and it was just we were sitting in an rv
for eight hours
and the only thing that got us through
was listening to out on the lanai
and we were like why don't we steal this
idea
and do it about drag race yeah
that's the ticket so we did so now we're
making our way
slowly but surely through the entire
you know uh series of drag race so we
watch
an an episode and then we discuss it we
talk about it
what's it like now to go back and and
watch from the beginning
do you see things that you didn't see
the first time around
oh definitely and i'm like such a i love
drag race so much
i i do go back and watch it for fun
anyway so that's why this project
works because it's something we [__]
do anyway right because we
love watching drag race then talking
[__] about it
and just like analyzing every detail
yeah i love going
i love going back like we just were
finishing up season five which was my
the first time i was on drag race and
it's like
flipping through a [__] photo album
and i'm looking at this young
you know this young version of myself
who didn't
know what they were doing and you know
it so
i don't know it's a it's a very special
time that i get to like revisit
that's very cool okay i want to talk to
you actually about that experience but
we're gonna take a quick break right
back uh
real quick and when we get back uh yeah
i wanna talk about
the first experience the second
experience and
what you might have learned what you
might have repressed so we'll be right
back with more not too deep
[Music]
the time is now to turn that dream that
you have into reality
with squarespace they make it easier
than ever to launch your passion project
do you want to start a new business do
you want to showcase your work do you
want to publish content or sell products
more perhaps more well squarespace is
the tool for you
with beautiful templates created by
world-class designers
you have the ability to customize just
about anything with a few clicks all by
yourself
you can make a beautiful website they
have a powerful ecommerce functionality
that lets you sell anything online
and analytics that help you grow your
site in real time
and everything is optimized for mobile
right out of the box there's nothing to
patch
or upgrade ever whatever those things
might mean you don't even have to worry
about them
buying domains is simple and you'll get
the help that you need with their 24
7 award-winning customer support they
empower millions of people
designers lawyers artists gamers
restaurants gyms
they help them turn great ideas into
something real so head to
squarespace.com
grace for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code grace
to save 10
of your first purchase of a website or
domain that's squarespace.com
grace offer code grace
let's talk about season five since
that's what you're going back to right
now currently on race chaser
uh what was that experience like i'm
sure you've talked about it ad nauseam a
million times but
now going back and watching yourself do
you have like a
a bit of tenderness for yourself because
it was your first
season you were way younger and you know
the
whole show was still like finding itself
too like what's that like
to see yourself yeah it is
weird watching myself because it it's
like seeing myself in utero
like i'm so i'm such a do i feel like
such a different person
right now and i'm like this this person
was
you know really um
didn't fully like didn't fully believe
in themselves
totally and like i don't know it is
touching to go back and watch and it's
like
that's such a moment in my life and and
i feel that for the
you know the the girls um from season 13
just got announced today and it's really
touching because it's like this is a
moment that's gonna change your [__]
your whole life mm-hmm and and
go get them kids it's beers it's great
like what rupaul has done with the show
is is
is i mean it's changed culture and it's
changed the world and it's changed
my life in so many people's lives truly
now when you
came back for all-star season two you
obviously
had a full season experience under your
belt did you go
back with any like new directive with
any sort of like
um change in the the play program or it
was the same let's see how it goes
well it was totally opposite because the
first time i went on
i was like well there's no way i'm gonna
win
uh because you know my
boyfriend at the time had just won the
season before so i was like
it's nice that they're letting me come
and play i'm not gonna win
then by the time all stars two came
around everyone was like oh my god
alaska's gonna win oh my god this is the
last because season you guys this is it
alaska's gonna win and i was like
well so okay that's a pressure a little
bit
yeah and i felt like i could win so i
was putting an immense amount of
pressure on myself
i went in very prepared yeah and
i feel like i did a good job competing i
did not have that much fun
competing because i was so stressed out
and putting so much pressure on myself
i wish i would have just smoked a joint
and like chilled out and had a good time
i probably still would have won but been
less of an
[__] but there is yeah there's when
you have those kind of expectations
that's why i'm so interested in when you
decide to come back you know what the
gauntlet is like you know how intense
the shooting days are like so you say
yes to all of this kind of wackiness and
then you also
want to win and you come back with
preparation to win so there's so many
expectations that's very difficult to
try and be
fun under those parameters
well i tried my best and you know like
you did
once i guess they did good
now do i'm assuming people um
ask you for advice all the time uh i'm
curious
what the worst piece of advice you've
ever gotten
may have been oh my god
or if there's one queen that you know
you never
ask for advice because they'll never
give you great advice
the worst piece of advice i was like
i got a tarot card reading in a
nightclub which was a mistake
and the per and i was like in this
relationship at the time and i was like
gonna break up with him and the tarot
card person was like
no give him a chance see it through
and then the guy like literally went
crazy and
like tried to he like stole my passport
and like tried to try to defame me
publicly and like was really really
so i shouldn't have um
that was bad advice yeah yeah yeah you
didn't want to give that guy a chance
i mean if i should have cut that off of
the past
fun the international travel could have
been
really so great uh
well this year uh it seems like you
obviously have put a lot more
time and energy into social media
because it's one of you know the major
outlets that we all have available this
year
i'm curious if you have a favorite
social media platform
is there are there people that you
follow that you look at every day
is it more of a passive thing for you
those are all horrible oh my gosh
oh
they've ruined the world they've ruined
my mind
i feel it rotting my brain from the
inside
i do yeah and i now i've
because i've been promoting the single
so much which usually i'm like
usually i post like once a year on
instagram and now
i'm like okay i have to compose a post
once a day
uh i have to sell the product um i have
to like get
this many likes or else i'm a failure
i it's horrible i hate i wake up
dreaming about insights and
posts and captions and i'm like
what is going on
so no it's all it's all horrible but um
uh twitter is funny and you can
show like you can show dicks and ass
and you know
so like i guess like if i had to like be
friends with one of the social media
platforms i would probably be with
twitter because it's like
the least uptight okay interesting
yeah but that is um it's very relieving
to hear you say that because
yeah i mean i my own personal experience
with social media is very
the push-pull very who trying to create
that healthy space but it's kind of hard
sometimes
tough and like what is it so like okay
if i don't get a certain amount of likes
on a post
then i'm ugly and i'm a failure but it's
like what
if what if i stopped doing the i was
still
working when i never posted so it's like
it's like on lost where they have to
keep putting the numbers in the thing
or else yes we don't know we don't know
what's gonna happen yes that's exactly
how it feels i also
in quarantine have just watched lost for
the first time this year so that's a
very
relevant reference for me right now and
i appreciate it
thank god it's relevant for you
but yeah it does feel like that it feels
like we're all working this machine
over and over for some result that
hasn't presented itself yet but instead
it's just making us more frustrated and
sad
while we're doing it that's so weird
it's very strange um i'm curious what
else have you been watching this year
have you gotten into any tv shows movies
anything like that um yes i mean i've
watched
like a lot of things i do we just
finished the selena
series which was fantastic and i can't
wait for part two
on [__] hbo max
i don't know yes it's in spanish but you
can watch it with really good
hbos dubbing oh
this ding dong
this is so good
just oh my god like it's a
it's about a trans icon from spain and
um it's a very nuanced and real
like life story that i'm just
about about someone who is really
complex oh my god it's so good i can't
say anything
again no okay i'm writing it down for
myself uh
that's great to know yeah i've just been
binging documentaries like crazy
and i don't know if it's helping or
hurting hence all the ufo documentaries
that i've been
seeing lately yeah did you watch um the
reagans
on show time no that's really fun no
okay another note for myself um
okay i have a question you've been
snubbed from the grammys this year
which is uh incredibly sad very
disappointing
yet again
do you have a an acceptance speech
prepared for when the time inevitably
comes
well i love references and i love
stealing so it would probably be
like it would probably i would probably
lift
shares acceptance speech from the oscars
word for word you know my mom
always told me i wasn't gonna be that
special but
i guess tonight maybe i'm on my way
thank you and i'm gonna trip falling up
the stairs and say [__]
which she also did oh i love that well i
can't wait for when we all get to
genuinely experience that moment
um i also have a question have you ever
thought
with your musical uh background and
everything you do in music
uh about creating alaska the musical
it's so weird that you because
literally i just did a thing with bob
the drag queen and
and uh she said the same thing
so like yes someday
it's in the air okay as long as it's in
the works
now what have you developed any
self-care
routines this year uh along with
creating music and doing all the the
performances that you've been able to do
what do you do when you just don't have
anything to do
that's so um that's a good question
i like um drawing oh really
that's something i always go back to
i've always done it ever since i was a
kid so i
love drawing if i like if there's
nothing else going on
then i love to do that um
self-care is like i mean
this pandemic early on
i was addicted to twitter and
and it it literally rotted a hole in my
brain and so i
had to stop and put it down
and now i don't do the i'm just
scrolling through
what's going on i don't do it because i
know that it makes me feel like [__]
um so i don't do it anymore good the
doomsday
doom scrolling yeah endlessly
so like i recommend that
i think that's a great idea yeah it's
one of those things i too
haven't realized how much time i just
spend mindlessly
going through my phone and i don't even
it's so unconscious like i don't realize
i'm doing it it's like my hands have a
different brain
than my head does it's very bizarre um
and it's not our fault it's designed to
be that way it's like a
it's like it's like a slot machine it's
made
to do that to to make your brain want to
keep
you know ding ding ding ding ding ding
like keep doing it
exactly uh well withdrawing i have a
question about how you create the
merchandise that you create
because i also see that not only do you
make
clothing and masks you have a little
pound cake the
doll that's available so what goes into
that kind of
stuff oh do we have a visual
i have one right here oh
it's amazing this is the official little
pound cake doll which is available on
alaskathunderfuck.com
the reason i bring that up is because we
have a warehouse full of them and we
need to [__] get rid of them
um yeah no i love i love
that um i love that aspect of
getting to do drag as like we get to put
our face
in our picture on stuff and then sell it
so like
we have a like there's just i don't know
i mean sometimes i
design it sometimes usually i work with
someone who you know comes up with an
illustration or like
an idea and and makes it [__] amazing
like i
love it i also wear all my own
merchandise
i think that's great you have to uh
the i know the little pound cake i think
is such a fun idea i can't wait for
children to get it
this holiday season don't give it to
children
it's like it's like an eight it's like
an nc 17
doll it literally it talks and it says
swear words
it does yeah i didn't realize it had
that capability that's incredible
i'm gonna reach in and squeeze her
you're like real daddy in here wow such
an angel
totally a beautiful cursed gift to give
your loved ones those holiday seasons
truly i love that
uh whatever any ideas for now
because i feel like that's a very
innovative piece of merch
are there any ideas to expand on a
little pound cake sort of family series
in any capacity
i kind of want to make like a limited
edition of her friends
because she has like she has two friends
like from the music video
right so like i don't like very limited
edition
i am not getting another warehouse full
i'm not doing it i'm gonna make like
five of each and be like
did you get one oh sold out like kylie
lip gloss
sold out i don't know so exclusive
um okay we're gonna take one last break
when we get back i have all these
wonderful questions from instagram that
are very thoughtful so we'll be right
back with more not too deep
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say
two things a big thank you for
listening to the podcast uh if you're a
regular listener if this is your first
time listening welcome and thank you
and uh second thing if you are enjoying
yourself here
in this not too deep world we've built
and you'd like to leave us a review that
would be
so wonderful if you can go to the itunes
store the app store and leave us a
lovely little
review comment how are you feeling good
bad otherwise maybe just good or
otherwise would be appreciated
other than that enjoy the podcast
okay alaska before we get into these
instagram questions i'm gonna ask you
the two questions
ask every single guest that is on the
podcast and the first is
who alive or dead would you most like to
throw cold spaghetti
at cold spaghetti
yeah alive or dead
i mean jared kushner yes
oh yeah that would be satisfying
i would i would uh yeah support that
200 percent um okay the other question
is to tell us your worst pant-shitting
story or a close
call but you can only use three words or
three small phrases
to describe the story so for instance
mine
is college jogging front lawn
yeah mine is
every couple of months
i appreciate that because i do feel like
uh that is something we're all kind of
experiencing right now
i love it um okay let's get into these
instagram
questions for you now um
someone wants to know a lot of questions
like this
what is your all-time favorite drag race
challenge
um um i like winning
stuff so oh my gosh like i love the
perfume challenge
[Applause]
because like that's that's like my
favorite thing to do is like
make a weird funny stupid little video
to sell [__] like that's what i love
doing and we got to do that for the
challenge and so
um that was really fun i feel like you
and willam
could in 2021 start your own version
of like the home shopping network and
just do
ads and run promo for all the different
products
i am not mad at that idea i love that
idea we can have liza minnelli on
yes it's fabulous it's just terrific
i love that uh someone's asking
do you have any projected trends
for 2021 in fashion
oh um yes uh well
this is what i hope happens i hope that
um
jeans under ball gowns oh
comes in like jeans under skirts
okay i love that i hope that comes back
i really hope because we sort of got
into this
sort of like only doing only looking
right from the waist up like sort of gig
right so i think it would be like a
commentary on that once we're out into
the world
i like that i mean like a waist down
sort of focus
now i'm so into it
uh someone's asking is there anything
that you've learned since starting
race chasers slash the mom network
anything i've learned um
i don't i mean or is there let's say
now that you're going back and
re-watching the earlier seasons of drag
race
is there something that's the most
surprising to you about
the early seasons that you might not
have noticed before
um i mean i feel like i've been such an
avid analyst of drag race
ever since the beginning like i which is
why i love
going back and re-watching and
re-watching it and and i think it's a
testament to
how well the show is made and the people
who make it
really care about the show and it is a
show that you can go back
and watch and re-watch i don't know that
all shows are like that
well i don't i i don't but it is really
good
and i love that about it and as far as
like the mom network
like i think that is like
you know it's more fun to do stuff with
your friends
so that's why you did it
we were like we like doing podcasting so
we invited our friends to do it too
that's great uh someone asked what's
your favorite experience of meeting a
celebrity
oh my god it's always i mean it's always
gonna be lady gaga
she creates she creates magic moments
she's the magic
[__] witch who creates just magic
moments in my life
but um aside from lady gaga who's
everything
um we ran into julie newmar
in an elevator um at the elvira
book launch event this is like a mad lib
sentence yeah
i know it was a small elevator and they
were only letting like a few
people in at a time and we ended up in
the elevator with julie newmar
wow and i and i was like i was like i
was like i'm gonna show you i'm gonna
say
and i was like you know i can't describe
you without using the word statuesque
which is a quote from two wong fu okay
and she just looked at me and she was
like
oh a perfect moment uh
someone wants to know how did you start
collaborating with yvonne and peter
um i don't know how that happened i
honestly don't
but we ended up like collaborating on a
song and it was called pool party
and like it has like five words and i
was like
okay this is this is a good beat this is
really fun
and it was really um it was a fun
experience
and people really liked the song and i
really like the song
and nice so we just kept working
together
someone wants to know what do you hope
the future
of your drag is
oh my gosh well i know that when i'm
like 90 i
i still want to i still want to be doing
drag even if it's like once a year for
like some big gala event but i just
envision myself like at 90 being like
propped up in the doorway like may west
just like done fulfilled
i i think that's fantastic that's what
the future needs
right now yes i'm into that i'm
into it uh someone wants to know and a
lot of people ask questions like this
how do you manage
reinventing but also staying authentic
and you kind of said earlier that every
time you try and do something new you
kind of come back to the
something that's a little bit more
familiar for you now do you
try to reinvent yourself or do you just
sort of continue to go with what feels
good for you
yeah i mean yeah like i like i said i
i do just like to do what i what feels
good and what i like but i guess it's
just like
i don't know doing that same thing over
and over again you
you still i'm still finding new stuff
about drag and like yeah
like i love watching james mansfield
youtube tutorials where
um she does she does wigs and like
she does amazing wigs so like i don't
know
i i like um learning get inspiration
that's great uh well you mentioned tarot
earlier and someone says
uh or asks how do you keep up with
mindfulness
uh slash being a beautiful spiritual
treasure
and so i'm curious uh is tarot something
because i think i saw recently you
posted a youtube video about
tarot as well right yeah is this
something that you're into
i'm not really into tarot because i'm
like don't tell me what don't
tell me what i'm supposed to do with my
life
yeah like i just don't like i don't like
that but
um um i
i mean as far as like spirituality goes
it's like
meditating is so important because it's
like
it's not about like okay what is
what do i have to do to be like to be
spiritual or to be enlightened
it's like usually what you have to do is
just like shut the sit down and shut the
[__] up
don't just breathe and don't do anything
which is really really hard especially
when we have the [__] devil box in
our phone
you know a hundred percent
uh but i think that it's good to know so
do you meditate daily
um i tried to i i tried to like at night
it's like my like wind down
nice nice nice um okay last question for
you before we wrap up
who would die first in a horror movie
you or willem
willem because she's a [__]
point blank point blank period
i think she would put up a fight she's
scrappy as [__] i would want to have her
on my team
but her love of dick would be the end of
her idea
and there you go that's all you got um
alaska this has been so fun before we
wrap
up completely we love to give our guests
a little token of our appreciation for
making time
and i believe melissa has emailed you a
personalized fortune cookie
from us to you if you're able to
yes please this is so cute okay
a far-off comet will soon align with the
planets
just right to bring alaska thunderf5000
back to her home planet but by the time
you finish reading this
you all have missed your chance try
again
in 600 years of crying but smiling emoji
which is the best emoji
yes i agree ah what a roller coaster
that really was suspenseful
now alaska um where can people find you
where can they get the
the music where can they listen to the
podcast also
new year's queens what's going on with
that if people don't already know
oh yeah i mean the best place to go is
just like
on instagram and it's um at the only
alaska 5000
um because some [__] stole
alaska [__]
okay um but it's the only alaska 5000
and um yeah new year's queens is going
to be really fierce there's like a
lineup of like
i don't know dozens of people it looks
amazing yeah
i'm gonna be hosting it live with bob
the drag queen and we're just gonna be
like
in the studio for [__] 12 hours just
time zone by time zone wow
um so yeah i don't know go to instagram
go to alaska
thunderfuck.com and i don't know stream
let it snow on [__] spotify
here we go please yes tis this season
uh well go check out everything that
she's up to there's something for
everyone fun for the whole
family there's dolls there's music
there's new year's streams it's all
there thank you so much
for your time alaska this is really fun
thank you i'm glad we got to talk
and i i your hair looks amazing oh thank
you it's very gross right now i've got
that pandemic
uh one cut of hair every six months
situation going on so thank you
no it looks fanta because i i watched
your um sleepy joe's
video and you were like i'm not i'm
wearing a hat because you don't want to
use but like your hair looks [__]
amazing pandemic
yeah i appreciate that very much that's
very i'll take that compliment very
deeply thank you
and we'll see you guys next time on
another episode of not too deep thanks
for listening and watching goodbye
too deep too deep too deep not too deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music